oh my gosh
[Music]
good morning
it is an early morning we're heading
down for breakfast and then checking out
of the hotel and then heading down to
San Diego because today's a cruise
breakfast time yummy
[Music]
all right we got Prince Luca here all
set up whole plate is for him not
croissant let's see how much he eats do
you love to eat huh baby
[Music]
now we're driving down to San Diego
real fast so I didn't Vlog any of this
but last night when we got back to the
road we were so exhausted my joints like
I feel my age my joints were killing me
like hip joints my knees my ankles my
elbows my shoulders literally all my
joints and I was like okay I need to lay
down I need to rest
and then I'll pack what ended up
happening was Casey ordered us some food
delivered to the hotel because room
service was pretty crazy I also it was
taking a really long time so we're like
okay now we're just gonna order some
food and it was due to come like at 12.
we ordered it like around 11 30 or
something I don't know I told Casey I'm
like I can't I can't hang I mean I need
to go to sleep
you know let me know when the food gets
here we'll eat and then we'll pack out
of like force a habit I put my phone on
do not disturb and the food delivery guy
came and they wouldn't let him come to
our room so he left the food he called
me three times and they left the food at
the front desk and then we didn't wake
up until like 1am like Casey woke up and
he's like oh my God the food like
where's the food because he ended up
falling asleep too like he goes to try
to find the food finds out that the food
had arrived an hour before and so that's
before they were like they didn't leave
a name or anything so we didn't know
what to do with this food so we threw it
away so I was like 80 dollars down the
drain we didn't get our food and then
yeah I wasn't gonna start packing at one
o'clock in the morning so we're just
like all right just wake up earlier and
just pack after breakfast and that's
exactly what we did we're just rushing
to pack because we need to be at the
port at a certain time
and it's also like pouring right now
this is very unsocal weather so it's
taking us a little longer to get there
but it'll be fine we'll we'll get on the
ship we'll be okay so I'm like trying
not to stress anyway I'm really really
tired I should be napping right now but
I'm like working on some other stuff for
a little less than 30 minutes away from
getting there so I'm gonna try to
squeeze in a little cat nap right now
we'll see because because Isaac has the
pillows well I have this little one but
anyway poor Casey sorry honey you're
like driving and tired
he's really tired also I did not take
off my makeup last night so what you see
here it feels last night's makeup or
yesterday's makeup my plan was to like
wash my face before we checked out of
the room and then do my makeup now on
the way there but now I'm like you know
what
is my look today this is how I'm gonna
look this is just
LOL
so Luca and I are all checked in for the
cruise
Casey and Isaac went to go park the car
across the street at a hotel and I
totally forgot to give them their
passports so now Luca and I have to wait
for them but we could have just
supported and then seen them later but
instead we're gonna wait it's not cool
then we get some board together but now
we kind of give them a little snack
s yeah
yeah you're about to do your first
Disney cruise actually all of our first
Disney Cruise we've never done a Disney
cruise before so I'm so excited yay your
first cruise ever though
all right we are reunited once again
over here
yes
[Music]
[Applause]
oh my goodness check out our room
this is set sail and bomb voyage
and we get a towel and look how sweet we
even got a nice little fruit basket gift
oh my goodness I'm so excited Luca are
you ready you match the room Luca what
you're wearing right now you totally
matched but look we also get a balcony
[Music]
we're in San Diego oh about to take off
to where we're going to Catalina back
home okay you won't let go let me see
let me see
[Applause]
oh you don't get vertigo dude
okay nice little fingerprints all over
the clean mirror I love it
he's like no filming now filming no
filming
I'm sorry
[Music]
sail away we're waiting for the
departure party and this is an
absolutely beautiful beautiful weather I
don't think we can have a better day
than Tuesday
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
of our 25th anniversary of Disney Cruise
Line
[Applause]
thank you
foreign
guys we just got an exclusive look at
Disney Cruise Line 25th anniversary
color scheme and we got to see Mickey
and Minnie's outfits for their
anniversary cruises which is gonna start
launching in may also by the way if you
know anything about me you know this is
my favorite color the fact that they
picked this color for their scheme is
this this is so me I love it
here's Luca's crib look at how adorable
he looks though
passed out
nice
[Music]
yeah I think it's one of the better
services on a cruise line I've ever had
yeah that we've ever experienced
[Applause]
[Music]
I feel it you feel the swaying
okay you feel that
it feels crazy
[Music]
all right we're having dinner now and I
ordered as cargo look at that it's so
cool they actually took it out of the
shell but in my opinion I think taking
it out of the shell is all part of the
fun but no worries and look at this cute
little tiny little French bread it's
adorable all right
cargo our car row
pretty good
[Applause]
[Music]
all right this is my lobster pasta it
smells incredibly lobstery AKA very
fishy it looks pretty good though let's
dig in I'm storing you vlogging while
holding Lucas he's trying to color it's
so cute oh my gosh you just threw it
he's over it oh Isaac what'd you get I
got a Sunday a Sunday
thank you so much
yummy creme brulee all right we just
finished dinner and we come back to a
very cool little um origami towel thing
yeah and we also received a gift from
Hulu who's gonna be sponsoring a party
later on in this trip sweet Hulu party
yeah Hulu silent DJ party I'm so scared
that he's gonna fall off the bed
he wants to party with Hulu too
cool
good morning this morning we are heading
down to Tiana's place to go meet Tiana
this time because we didn't get to meet
her when we did the New Orleans uh Mardi
Gras morning and I was really bummed
because the night before my water broke
we were watching Princess and the Frog
so it has like a little extra special
place in our heart because the next day
technically
two days later because Luke I was born
in the middle of the night but that's
when Luca came we've been wanting to
meet her during this trip and now we
finally get to meet her so I'm really
excited
we're at Tiana's place look at this
Tiana's here cheers
[Music]
it's so nice to meet you it's so
beautiful
all right we are out on the deck today
we have a beautiful day ahead of us and
Catalina all right Luca what are we
gonna do today at Catalina Islands would
you like to ride bikes with us would you
like to rent a golf cart golf cart let's
try to do a golf cart today
right behind you
[Music]
we're finally headed to Catalina so
the three of us we the kids two three we
slept for two hours much needed rest and
pretty much like waste of
the foot now we're like squ eezing the
last last bit of time together
I guess
[Music]
we're heading towards
Catalina
for like a very short amount of time
[Music]
yeah there we go just like the old days
still still got it you feel Rusty as
hell oh my God there's a camera on my
face what do I do
we returned who would have known the
next time we came we came back we could
come back with another baby no it's a
new family member actually Isaac's never
been here true junior family members
never came with Isaac every time we've
been here it's always just been with me
and you
okay we're trying to come back now
everyone else trying to return back to
the ship
one hour
that's all we never they need I know
this place this place is so cute and
tiny you can literally walk
we could walk from one end to another
and like four times in an hour we'll be
really exhausted though in that pace it
would be a very fast pace but still we
could do it true true all right I think
I've seen enough you guys ready to go
back all right let's go
all right check out the wheels oh check
out these wheels they're stuck
in here nice and safely he's still
eating that applesauce so funny there's
like nothing left in there but he just
has it like a pacifier
a lot of potholes look at that I'm so
happy it's not raining right now
so fun fact Catalina has no mostly
mostly golf carts but there are some
cars like in this cop car but there's
also like and I want him to see me
reporting them so I'm like only pretend
I'm recording something else
[Music]
my hair is going wild
I wonder see you in less than an hour it
is 3 50. you guys like my wallpaper it's
so cute I love it so what time are you
trying to get back get back to the town
4 15. yeah and then like to drive around
maybe shop and then yeah shop for a
little bit
I had to put my hair up because my hair
was going wild you look beautiful thank
you come on baby let's take a picture
really fast look at the view
[Music]
Catalina not really we're just at a
really high package point oh look it's
way over there having fun
[Music]
this is freezing in the back it's
actually colder it's sitting in the back
than in the front obviously actually if
you get blown back yeah there's just
more wind that craps around the uh the
the front window I don't like it all
right it's 4 15.
look at this kid he just got a new fit
let me see let me see so it says stay
salty Catalina Island look nice
we also got him another uh sweater a
crew neck that says Catalina so he can
remember his less than one hour of fun
here in Catalina Island
cheers
how beautiful this restaurant is and
then they gave us this paper here so you
can draw your own character and as long
as we draw inside the blue lines and
then we put our name and table number
it'll pop up on that screen right over
there Casey's working on drawing Luca
what are you gonna draw I don't know
figures
so I don't know I don't even know if I'm
gonna do this assignment because it's
just I'm embarrassingly but I'm drawing
I didn't see the end results because I
already took it but now
what's going on
oh you're good
you should be these animators
[Music]
that's what I mean
have a mission of magic
[Music]
[Applause]
even though Casey's such a great artist
he still can't do hands and Skip down on
hands hands are hard greater than mine
this is all I got a curly haired woman
with gigantic lips I tried doing some
Mickey ears I have no idea what to do
for her body though stay tuned okay so
this is what I ended up with I don't
know how I started here and then I tried
doing her legs but the marker ran out so
we did some pants and then the shoes
came out looking like a witch because I
was actually copying this one
I told you guys I am not an artist I
cannot draw
[Music]
oh
[Applause]
okay we just finished the deportation
party
she chicken
totally legal you're not supported
[Music]